welcome back to new rock stars I'm Eric
Voss and now that Marvel's Echo Series
has had some time to breathe we're
asking the question did Marvel bury Echo
did it bury this show and do it a
disservice with this release strategy of
all episodes at once at the beginning of
the year not because Marvel Studios
Disney knows better than anyone how
effective it is to do a week-by-week
release strategy and how much that
continues to build the momentum around a
Show's media Buzz so knowing what they
know did they intentionally bury the
show did they overmal with Echo and take
away what was so good about it from Just
A Creative standpoint to try to force it
into a round Peg by having too many um
you know MCU tie-ins of like Kingpin of
magor of Daredevil when this really
could have just been Marvel
Studios Unforgiven Marvel Studios A
History of Violence um you know we're
going to talk about it in this episode
uh and Marvel Studios you're on watch if
you don't release any other title that
has Marvel Spotlight we're going to know
what you did with this show uh this is
the sneak peek where we take the
temperature of whatever we are watching
while we look ahead to the next week in
nerdom uh Jessica is getting some
well-earned rest as she broke down every
single episode of Echo and did an
amazing job I learned so much just from
watching her breakdowns joining me this
episode all the way from kingpen
homeland of the state of New York it's
Tommy be told yes just a short 7 hour
drive from the Big Apple uh beautiful
Rochester New York we're getting excited
about the Buffalo Bills Eric apologies
to your Jaguars you did Vanquish US
during the regular season oh God they're
stopping watching The Views are going
down Marvel Marvel Marvel Marvel Star
Wars Marvel hey we're getting some other
views coming in I mean look all the all
the Tennessee Titans fans you guys have
ruined so many of our Seasons Titans God
why did you even have to I hate the
Titans I hate them those fans Jags fans
hating the Tennessee Titans that's what
we can do and uh at the very end of this
video I'm going to share my ranking of
every MCU title since Avengers endgame I
personally just don't feel like it's
fair to compare the current Marvel
titles to everything that came before
endgame I think at some point I will
share my master ranking of everything I
can can we do that in tuxedos uh at like
a theater and we'll reveal the list like
uh like an a show the reason why like
I'm reluctant to do it is like it keeps
changing and Kevin feig keeps bringing
in like the Marvel Netflix shows and the
X-Men continuity and eventually we're
just going to have to rank like over a
hundred titles Eric are you saying that
you're you're allowing yourself to
evolve and change in your opinions on
Art I don't know about that I think you
should be steadfast and stubborn oh my
God you're right Tommy lock him in lock
him up hey I'm going to get into a pitch
in this discussion that like roxson
could have been a more effective villain
of this series than Kingpin was but
before we even get to that I want to
make something clear at the top of this
discussion uh Tommy and I both
independently really loved a lot about
this Echo series and we join everyone
who feels seen in this show maybe we
don't have that same kind of life
experience but we celebrate the fact
that this character exists in the MCU
and we love what alaka Cox did with the
character we love what the writers did
with this character everyone who
consultant on this show they did so many
things really well and this is such an
important show and we're going to get
critical on it but our criticisms are
not directed at like the fact that they
have this character in the MC I know
there's a lot of people online who are
criticizing this show for just unfair
reasons and that's not what we're doing
here we're looking at what the studio
did and the way that they released it
and the way that they produced it and I
think uh it's very clear that they
changed things about this show uh from
reducing storylines to adding things
that didn't need to be in the show
especially in the first episode um and
we're just gonna talk about Marvel
Studios as a whole I think it's a fair
question to ask did they bury this show
did they bury what was good about it and
did they bury what could have been great
about it existing in the MCU and I think
that's a fair conversation to have I
don't think that makes this haters I
think it's it's a conversation that
needs to be had both internally at
Marvel Studios and within the nerd
sphere where Tommy and I are part of it
sure well Eric I'm going to commit a
cardinal sin number two and make another
Sports comparison but I think it is it
is pertinent to to this when you're when
when you're a like world class level
figure skater or gymnast or something
that requires complicated complex
routine with multiple different elements
and you do every element at a high level
at at a at a like Elite level when you
make a mistake it is glaring so I feel
like for Ekko for me it was like a
really well skated Olympic figure
skating performance that the the skater
slipped and fell a couple times and
those because the rest of it was so
beautiful and and well well done the
moments that fell flat fell flatter than
they might have had it just been you
know someone skating around a pond or
something like that you know it just I
think they nailed so much of it that it
made the parts that didn't ring true or
felt tacked on or or or or re-edited or
recut uh especially glaring to me yeah I
think honestly I'll extend that
comparison I think it took an Olympic
class skater and instead said hey could
you run the DECA could you could you
actually be a swimmer now or could you
actually do your figure skating on Sand
instead of on ice like it started to
make a show that was clearly great at
one thing try to Pivot and do these
other things unfortunately for the show
like the character Ekko it felt like
this show had to live in multiple worlds
and that we completely understand is a
different burden on Ekko than it is on
like uh even like a show like a Hawkeye
you know um it's it's it's completely
unfair they are fighting uphill in so
many ways on this show and I think
Marvel Studios just put these weird
roadblocks in place because they just
lost confidence in this show and they
didn't need to like and it's this is a
difficult thing when you look at the the
pitch the premise of this show there is
a great show here it is a great idea to
take a character who is an assassin from
the big city criminal underworld working
under a Kingpin who decides to leave
that life who breaks free of that life
go to their hometown and then try to
find peace but get dragged back into the
violence that is a classic Western story
that always works A History of Violence
such an amazing show that was based on
you know a literary Source material um a
show a title like Unforgiven Clint
Eastwood's Unforgiven it's one of the
Best Westerns that deconstructs the
Western mythology same kind of thing you
lone Gunslinger Tred to leave the
violence behind them gets dragged back
into it and scares the hell out of
everyone still part of that game um
Logan if you would look at the Marvel
World Logan is basically Marvel's
version of Unforgiven A Lone Wolf and
Cub story where Logan wants to just be a
limo driver and get a get away from that
life and just gets dragged back into it
and has to kind of you know make some
personal sacrifices and get his hands
bloody again and how painful that is so
that should have been the case for May
for Maya Lopez while I was watching the
show I was reminded of a uh Breaking Bad
better call saw one of the best
characters on TV mikee ER Trout from
started as just like a side character on
Breaking Bad but they filled out his
story on Better Call Saul he's a
character who is a Philly cop who is
involved in corrupt uh police Vengeance
seeking and it's basically what he did
he got Vengeance for his son who got
caught up in some corrupt cops and then
um made did some and then fled out
west to New Mexico and try to just have
a stable life but then due to his nature
gets dragged back into it and has to
deal face to face with like various drug
cartels and Drug kingpins in the better
call SA Breaking Bad universe and that's
what this show could have been but I
feel like there was a disagreement
between Sydney Freeland and Brad wibom
about what Maya Lopez needed to be in
the MCU and they constructed what I felt
was an inauthentic relationship between
Wilson Fisk and Maya Lopez Maya Lopez
has a relationship with Wilson Fisk in
the comics but they settled that in
Hawkeye and then after she shoots him
that relationship should have been done
and in her past but basically the latter
or two episodes of this season just made
her retread through that and we never
really learned much I was far more
interested about Maya Lopez's
relationship with her mother her
deceased mother her grandmother with
Chula with um with biscuits biscuits
Bonnie her sister with Henry how did
they not name Biscuit's dog gravy the
dog's name should have been gravy I
mentioned that uh yesterday I don't get
it uh but yeah I I I I talked for a long
time no no that's fine I was I was was
uh I I I agree uh for the most part I my
big question is the more involved with
Kingpin now you can argue the
manipulative dynamics of like an adult
figure to a child figure but like at a
certain point Maya becomes irredeemable
right like it's like like she her
translator gets murdered as a tying up a
loose end and like you could say like oh
maybe she didn't hear but she knew that
that lady was getting killed like it's
like she saw a lot of in people die so
like at a certain point I guess maybe
not so much in in comic book movies or
you know or or or uh huge like bu like I
guess I guess when it's like a franchise
it's like the everyone's redeemable
because you want to be able to bring
them back but I felt like the deeper
they went into like I kind of I enjoyed
the performances between Vincent Deano
and alaka Cox but I agree there was
really no need for him to be the big bad
and in a way because they shoehorned him
in as the big bad it was very
unsatisfying at the end I mean I I yeah
I was I I left that last episode being
kind of it felt to me like they they
just packed up the set like it was like
there's still there's still two Vans
full of guys with guns that just had
their roofs pushed in a little bit like
those guys are all alive and still armed
like where were they why didn't they get
involved yeah a lot of a clear this was
going to be a six episode season they
reduced it down to five and just from
episode one we knew something was going
on because they clearly pitched this
show as a Marvel Spotlight series and
what did they do in episode one they
basically spent 15 minutes doing it
previously on yeah like that is that
what makes it Spotlight if it's just
like now super connected to what we
already saw on Hawkeye we didn't need
that um like you could have just done
previously on the MCU there where Disney
plus gives you the option to skip it if
you don't need it and just go right into
her going like I think the issue is
Jessica pointed this out in her
breakdown of episode 3 and episode 4 um
where it looked like Kingpin was even on
a green screen just the way that scene
was lit uh where he first appears in
front of the house um and to me that
like that even uh reflects the way I
feel about his role in the show and I
say this to someone who loves denafo I
love Kingpin and I'm excited to see
where he's going to the MCU this was not
his story this was ekko's story and what
they did in effect an argument could be
made is that they treated this as like a
Dances with Wolves with Kingpin where he
goes out to uh to tribal country to the
CH on Nation heals his generational
trauma and then gets to go back and run
for May feeling empowered because he
basically goes on this uh spiritual
Quest and that's that's
obviously not what the writers wanted
from this show King in this you Empower
him to be like a protagonist figure and
that's not what should have happened
with the series especially given the
fact that we already know that he did
want to kill her father like that he is
he is L it's like it's not like there's
going to be a moment where you're like
oh I'll be convinced maybe Kingpin could
win me over it's like you know I don't
know I just uh I I agree so much of it
uh I I found enjoy the performances of
the side characters were truly I mean
you get Graham
green uh who's just been in everything
and was amazing as Scully and then you
get uh you get the the guy who played
Uncle Henry was fabulous I thought and
like interesting and kind of like a
little bit he reminded me a little bit
of like a uh
martial arts action star of in the 90s
and 80s because he had great facial over
exaggerated facial reactions which is
kind of like a no no in in like
traditional acting school but I think
that guy and in that performance it
totally worked like his him being very
expressive kind of played along to the
guy a man who lives a double life as a
uh import export person uh and and a
roller rink owner like that guy's going
to be qu that's that's two worlds
merging together as well so I I'm just
not that interested in um Maya's and and
Wilson fisk's relationship going forward
and I think one issue is by making
Kingpin the big bat at this show you're
forcing someone into uh this town that's
amazing Community fascinating community
of tamaha a community that Wilson Fisk
has no relationship with other than Taya
right and like we saw a roxson gas
station how much of an actual history do
we have in this country of oil companies
plundering stealing This Land why can't
you just make a roxon oil conglomerate
and then put some big bad from the
comics in charge of that but someone who
is like killers of the flower Moon
stealing This land from uh from
indigenous peoples and then basically
plundering it for its wealth I mean if
you want to get MCU about it you could
even have like Val or someone find some
kind of like uh Enchanted quality about
the land and mine it for that for
Quantum or whatever you want to do but
is someone who has like a relationship
uh that is more tied in with the themes
of of tamaha of Chula of Scully uh and
with Maya but instead they just relied
on this uh this kind of structured
backstory where Maya as a girl saw
Wilson fist beating to death an ice
cream vendor and getting activated by
that and like if this is supposed to be
the same Kingpin from the Netflix shows
you mean to tell me the whole time that
we saw him dealing with Vanessa with
rabbit snowstorm with everything he had
this niece on the side that like is now
so important to him like it just I think
and I again Sydney Freeland the writers
of the show obviously had a goal in mind
with this show but by make like by
forcing it to be something that it did
not need to be Marvel Studios is trying
to figure out a way to sell it more but
at the same time they dumped it all at
one time and now no one is talking
talking about the show no one is
watching it and instead you're
delivering a piece of content that feels
false that feels like it's been meddled
with that feels like it's been tainted
to people are going to love it and they
have to kind of defend it on two
different fronts and that's just not
fair I think to the people who were
waiting for this show and could have had
a really great Simple Pure thing that
was just telling the story of Maya Lopez
and her family I mean I I'm going on to
terar right now I say this as someone
who loved the prologue of the show I
love the history of the chalk t ation of
her ancestors I thought that was so cool
like the clay texture of everything like
that was interesting to me um but it
just felt like a completely different
show than what was sold to us through
trailers and it just feels like you're
doing it at a disservice if you just
don't tell if you don't sell it for what
it's going to be and how cool it's going
to be yeah I agree I agree I know it
sounds biased because I'm a Creator but
being creative is kind of the best like
being able to have an idea in your head
and then have it take form in the world
is super satisfying and it's easier to
do it when you're using skillshare
skillshare is the largest online
learning community for creatives it's
got thousands of classes led by
professionals from basically every
creative industry from film to Fine Arts
and every creative Niche from clation to
composition whether you're looking for a
new hobby or ready to turn your hobby
into a side hustle skillshare can help
they've designed specialized learning
paths just for you when you are on your
creative Quest every learning path has
handpicked classes meant to be taken in
order that build on another reinforcing
the lessons of the previous classes and
letting you learn out your own Pace want
to start your own YouTube channel
skillshare has learning paths just for
that it's got over 10 hours of classes I
checked out some because why not and the
classes on how to be on camera is super
useful because I am not actually good at
being on camera it's crazy how much of
this stuff that feels like there's
nothing to it actually has a lot to it
no matter what you want to learn drawing
editing design there's a learning path
just for you even if you want to learn
one particular tool to help you
professionally like procreator blender
skill shares got you covered the first
500 people to use the link in the
description to sign up we'll get one
month free trial of skillshare so start
your year off right with skillshare it's
it's hard and I understand I it sounds
like I'm being really negative I I I
think I think you're very much handling
it it's tough for us to sit here as two
straight white guys and like get get
technical about a show that is being
assailed and and attacked for completely
irrational untechnical points by smooth
brained idiots on the internet so it's
like if we want to argue the merits of
the storytelling the cohesiveness and
the the whole product that's something
that you and I and and hopefully fans of
new rockstars can enjoy and do
unfortunately like trying to have that
discourse with someone on the internet
who just is like MCU or Marvel woke or
whatever is like it's not going to work
out and they're never I mean the the sad
thing for them is they'll never get to
enjoy the stuff that really sailes and
takes off and you know and I feel bad
for them but it also puts us in a
predicament because it's like yeah I
don't really want to rail on this show
that I think think was pretty flawed
because I feel like of all the like with
all the negativity out there that's
being put on it unfairly it's like some
Fair negativity just kind of adds fuel
to the idiot fire so I'm like I'm with
you it's tough I don't think you're
being inherently negative I think you're
being incredibly fair with the overall
what the product was what the actual
literal tangible what we saw with our
own eyes product was I think you're
doing an incredibly Fair analysis of it
unfortunately horrible internet Discord
makes it very hard to thread that needle
these days so yeah we're kind of a rock
in a hard place it's tough I honestly
you know we get criticized a lot on new
rock stars of like being chills or being
like woke about stuff I don't even know
what woke means uh and I used to think
that like uh the you know certain forces
in this company who love to use that ter
in this company in this country who love
to use that term don't know what it
means I now believe that they have in
their mind a a shared understanding of
what woke means I do not know and I feel
like the only way we're going to Fig I
have to kind of know what they mean by
and my understanding is the the
traditional the origin of the word woke
was stay aware of your surroundings and
stay present for your own safety and
that dealt with uh marginalized
communities and people that were you
know facing racism sexism whatever big
any bigotry of all forms staying woke
meant be like keep your head on a swivel
and be aware of people that maybe out to
hurt you that was like the original
meaning of it right I felt like I
understood I used to know what it meant
and now just mean something different
now it basically just means not straight
white right it's code it is completely
code it's for anything that um uh people
on the right in this country feel like
is pushing a political agenda on them
but the problem is is they keep moving
the goalpost and now anything that's
just mere representation just having
tiona Paris on a thumbnail of a video to
them is woke and it's like how is that
woke just to show a person of color
explain to me what political agenda was
accomplished in Echo if you're telling
me that that show was overly politicized
I don't think I don't think there is one
I think the key message of it was I mean
me talking about Andor just the the fact
that a character's political diet tribe
has roots in The Communist Manifesto
acknowledging the existence of the
Communist Manifesto is woke and it's
like what the hell are you talking about
this is just a historical document that
inspired a lot of different people in a
lot of different ways like what are you
talking about I think a lot of uh people
that will share that opinion uh of of of
labeling everything well a little bit
like brick Tamlin in Anchor Man they
don't really know what they're saying
they just know that they're adults and
so if they speak people will reactionary
listen to them so they just say things
like woke and like the country is going
down the tubes and like Marvel is broken
or whatever and it just unfortunately it
gets it gets ears uh it gets listens
yeah I think it means like it's used by
people who wake up every morning ready
for a fight on the internet and that's
not how I begin every day but it's it's
just it's folks who are expecting to be
like victimized well that's good cuz you
have you have a
baby I would love if I'm dealing with a
different battle if your if your baby
was just laying down and you're just
furiously tweeting over
him um so that Tommy and I kind of gone
on on off a tangent here but it is
reflecting how hard it is to talk about
this show and to be critici uh to be
critical of anything surrounding it
because I think a lot of people uh on
the other side are committing to these
talking points of only saying positive
things about the show because they don't
want the studio to get the wrong message
and never ever make another uh property
about this they don't want to like step
on any eggshells they don't want to get
like canceled by any other kind of
faction on the internet and I think that
also does the disservice to it because
it's uh because yes this show is flawed
and uh the success of a TV show when
it's successful like Loki season 2
everyone can take part in that success
from the creatives from the writers from
the actors from the production designers
to the studio because a TV show is a
commercial product and the studio
deserves credit for putting together a
great creative team and successfully
marketing it and and branding it and all
that stuff um we're not just criticizing
a single painting that one artist hung
up on a wall we're we're criticizing
something that was designed to sell
products with like product placement
that kind of thing um so all that said
all that said I just believe Marvel had
a great opportunity here and I remember
being at d23 with you Tommy back in 2022
Anaheim and seen the very first teaser
for that and there was a lot of black
and white footage of of uh indigenous
tribes wor in against each other and it
seemed like a very different show and I
was really intrigued to see what this
show could be and then from that to um
whenever that was in late 2023 where
they released a trailer and it was like
a season of Punisher it just felt like
Marvel got their hands on this they
didn't have confidence in it and to me
my favorite episode of what if and I
don't mean to just like compare every
other story of of indigenous groups and
say that they should all be the same
thing that's not what I'm saying but the
fact that Marvel allowed the creative to
just take control of the city episode of
what if and how great of results they
got out of that they committed to it and
they didn't try to uh alter it or change
it into something that it wasn't um and
that ended up being my favorite episode
um for so many reasons um it just felt
like such an interesting story it was
the truest sliding door um truth to the
idea of and sentiment of what what if
should be I felt in season two and I
just really enjoyed it um Marvel had an
opportunity to do the same with Eko and
I think they got scared I think by
dumping it all at once they knew what
they were doing they knew that like the
world would move on from it in a couple
weeks uh and I just think that's a shame
and I mean I hate to say it but they
probably knew that in like about about a
month we're all going to be ragging on
Madam web's uh ridiculous Ocean Spray
cranberry uh revealed suit and they're
like all right well that's Tech
techically a Marvel Studios film I guess
right like aren't they Co all producing
conjunction but they're like less blood
on less Ocean Spray on our hands with uh
with with Madam web so I mean look yeah
I mean I say this as someone who I uh I
enjoyed honestly seeing Wilson Fisk in
this show I enjoyed seeing uh Matt
Murdoch um Charlie Cox I like these
fights but it just it I ALS like I
didn't need them in the show to enjoy it
I don't think they I don't think they
move moved the story forward at all or
or or added any levels to the character
that I think I already had a good grasp
on who Ekko was prior to the you know
the um yeah the Daredevil fight at least
I I will also say I think one criticism
I will um wager toward the the creatives
of the show is the uh changing of ekko's
powers there was a a comment made to
variety by uh Sydney Freeland early
before the series came out that they
decided to change ekko's powers from
what they were in the comics which is
similar to Taskmaster yes you know Ekko
is known as someone who can kind of
mimic any fighting move and stay like a
millisecond ahead of it um uh Sydney
Freeland said quote you know we felt
that was kind of lame and then they
wanted to and she wouldn't say the
interview what her powers would be but
what they ended up settling on in the
show is something similar to what we've
seen in recent Marvel titles which I
think the first time we saw it basically
one's P it begins with like a young hero
who's uncertain of their power
but then looks back through history at
their matriarchal lineage and by coming
to terms with it and embracing it some
in some kind of embrace through history
is able to empower themselves in some
surprising way and then start glowing
and then blast light and then basically
um blind their enemies right like so we
saw that with M Marvel we saw that
effectively with SH and black panther
wakanda forever um uh if you listen to
the ringer verse uh podcast from the
midnight boys Charles Holmes explains
this far better than I do shout out to
all those guys over there where Charles
kind of goes um into his explanation
that like Marvel keeps doing this thing
of like from the dawn of time and then
just this kind of ancestral story and
what what makes Marvel uh Comics so
interesting to many readers is like this
the idea that the power itself isn't
what is sacred the power is supposed to
be kind of some incidental accidental
thing Miles Morales gets bit by a spider
that he wasn't supposed to be bit by and
then he he becomes Spider-Man and he
brings his his culture his story to that
role um now you could say Marvel Comics
gave the Spider story far more sacred
Power by saying it was an arachno
frequency through the web of life and
Destiny but still the idea is that all
the spiders who got bit in these
respective universes it was just kind of
like a random silly thing and each of
them brought their worlds to the role um
but by saying that like your power comes
from the fact that you were destined
through your bloodline to do this um I
think it can be an effective way to
bring catharsis to people who feel like
they should be ashamed of their story so
I think it works but if you keep doing
it again and again and again it kind of
waters down the power of it um and I
think what I like about Echo Comics is
that this is I I understand um The
Writer's perspective that that could be
a bit problematic that like oh her
disability is now like a power like you
know Daredevil's idea that oh because he
is blind he can enhance hearing there's
something about that I get that but
there's so many other ways that you
could just make her power just something
that is incidental to who she is the
power should not be like fused I don't
know I'm saying should but it's just
like if it's it's tough like I think if
you make it so much about like she was
destined to be through her ancestry uh
to have this power and if that power is
just glowing and we tell the actor just
react to glowing on your hands and then
blast glowing through your hands it's
like we just keep seeing that with
Marvel and it just doesn't really seem
to have any tactile weight when they
blast people does it zap them does it
cut through their flesh when you blast
them they keep doing that where they
like 80% of powers in the MC are just
like glowing radiation and that's it we
don't know what it is I agree I agree
and I you know it's like well perhaps
all this will be rendered moot when the
with the introduction of the X-Men and
the Fantastic Four who all kind of like
their names are their powers it's like
yeah yeah you know it's it's funny I
we're we're breaking down the X-Men uh
Series right now and I talk about how
like with the early OT X-Men movies they
seem to sideline James Marsen a lot
which is a bummer because he's so good
and in my opinion like Cyclops should be
the leader of the X-Men like we should
see the ethical choices but they
sideline him because Wolverine ended up
being the bigger star and they wanted to
explore the Phoenix Saga um but uh I
think it's really just a practical thing
because in the early OTS the visual
effect of the optic blast was really
hard to do now it's a lot easier now
it's a lot easier but um like with Iron
Man they figured out a new aesthetic of
it and it felt like with the first Iron
Man we knew what it looked like when
Tony Starks repulsors hit something seem
to have a weight now it's just like the
Marvels are just blah BL BL just
spitting light at each other and we
don't really know if it hurts right um
how much it hurts like does it does it
melt metal does it uh cutes like piping
hot or is it you know icy cold or what
is it like Doctor Strange just kind of
blasts light at thing and it's like
should that cut them in half or does it
just like slap them does it just push
them back can I eat the light can I
snort the light can I can I can I can I
use the light to light my domicile I
don't know you're right yeah this is
something that the yeah the boys does it
really well when uh you know when
homelander uses his heat vision on
things and then people bleed like we're
afraid when his eyes start to go like
it's terrifying uh but the MCU it's just
like so soft we don't know what it means
when start glowing less light more
fight just have an impact just yeah I
think you're I think that's the main
thing like just give us an effect like
what does it do well how does this how
does this affect that if if you're
getting blasted by something is it just
overwhelming pressure or force is it you
know is it like getting punched is it
like getting stabbed is it like getting
shot we just need to know that um so
Lessons Learned I think um Marvel
Studios if I have to applaud Disney and
Marvel Studios for taking the step to
even like Greenlight these but if you're
going to Greenlight it you have to
follow through and you just have to let
the the project be what the project is
and you're not going to score any points
by putting Kingpin and Daredevil in it
because the the guys who only want to
see Daredevil and Kingpin stories are
not going to be fooled by coming over to
a you know you're not going to win them
over that way by tricking them like just
be honest be transparent about what
story you want to tell and then let
those stories breathe yeah let let let
the audience find those stories um so
I'm with you it's a shame it's a shame
because I I really loved so much about
the show and I hope we see I hope we see
Ekko again I hope we see some of these
characters again but I just don't think
we will yeah you got I don't think we
will yeah that'll be it I mean hey maybe
we'll see I mean we'll see obviously
Kingpin again we might see Ekko show up
in there's 18 episodes of Daredevil born
again if you don't let her show up in
one of those 18 episodes it's going to
be like yikes guys come on looking ahead
now yes um heat check before we go
because you know Tommy you and I haven't
talked in a while I want to know from
you how optimistic are you about Marvel
in 2024 with X-Men 97 your friendly
neighborhood Spider-Man Isa wakanda but
then also Deadpool 3 in Act of the
darkhole Diary uh I'm a I'm a variety of
levels of enthusiasm and uh and hopeful
uh X-Men 97 I'm never betting against
our boy Frank Moran that's going to be
an absolute Banger uh uh I think I think
I think X-Men 97 I for me that's just
going to be something I'm gonna enjoy as
a fan you know I I I I'll be happy to
talk about it on on this channel but I I
just that that cartoon was such a uh
part of my routine as a as a kid so I uh
I look forward to going back into that
world uh friendly neighborhood
Spider-Man that I I have that's probably
the project I'm the least familiar with
I think is is this an animated show
about him in high school right yeah it's
uh it was originally Spider-Man freshman
year it's an animated series that just
kind of takes Peter back to the high
school I mean I think these are great
ways to get kids that come home after
school and watch TV to to get into the
MCU I mean they a back to our way to get
them into Marvel products uh Deadpool 3
I'm very excited and bullish on I feel
like as long as they don't uh as long as
there's not too many chefs in the
kitchen now with uh with it being a
Disney produced movie I'm I'm very
bullish on that uh eyes of wakanda I
think again they're just going to have
to deflect morons and idiots that are
going to critique it for no reason and
other than that I'm excited about it and
the thing I'm most excited about uh is
of course my sweet sweet Agatha and uh
and the dark old Diaries you gotta be
kidding me uh green light 10 more
episodes of that right now Agatha uh the
whole gang Patty Leone she better sing
I'll tell you that much she better sing
her little heart out uh is it Eric Andre
in uh darkhole Diaries or is that a
rumor oh I remember seeing that rumor
I'm not sure okay if Eric Andre is in it
I I I I mean I I'll watch it regardless
but it'll it'll jump up a level for me I
love him uh yeah I'm excited for those
you know what I'm always going to be
optimistic even even when we kind of
have tough tough cookies like this one
uh you know and you secret Invasion
certainly uh tested a lot of our faiths
as well it's like I I'm always going to
hope I I I I love these movies and I
love these shows I'm going to root for
them to do well and I'm going to assume
that they're going to do a good job and
then I will be here on sneak peek to
pick up the pieces when they when they
fall but Eric who cares what I think I
want to know what the Voss man thinks
about these projects coming up give me
your heat check I feel like I've been
talking so that's all right rapid fire
baby X-Men 97 yeah X-Men 97 uh 10 out of
10 excited for could not be more excited
not just because Frank is writing for it
I think that's going to be great um I
got to say uh what if season 2 I thought
was a little mixed so I'm not really
sure whether Marvel animation is where
it needs to be right now it's
specifically because of the art
direction that Marvel Studios has
enforced on these shows where they have
to look like you know the MCU liveaction
version of it it limits how crazy
animation can get and with animation I
want to see the variety I want to I
don't want to see a character who looks
like Sebastian Stan I want to see some
just looks like a crazy silhouette and
go crazy with it anyway so friendly
neighborhood Spider-Man Isa wakanda I'll
wait till I see a trailer I saw the
concept are whenever they did that panel
like a year and a half ago and I'm just
like all right um Deadpool 3 and a of
the darkle Diaries also 10 10 I think
Deadpool 3 is gonna be super crazy and I
don't get it how people are like AA
didn't need a spin-off it's like if any
character from MCU phase 4 deserved a
spin-off it was and also I think the
nature of fandom online fandom on social
media specifically is let something go a
long enough time without it coming out
and people will invent ways to to
criticize it before it comes out like if
something doesn't get released within
like six months of it being announced
it's like oh well now we get to just
speculate and you know it's like it's
not it's not any different than people
who have to go on news channels or
Sports networks and give a new take
every day like there's inevitably going
to be people that were like Agatha is is
everything Agatha is Mother that like
are now probably tweeting out like oh
great another spin-off for a useless
side character so you know I think we're
just in we're in a we're in a real heavy
take Zone these days everyone's got to
have a take so H but I'm excited baby
I'm excited yeah uh as promised at the
beginning of this episode I told you I'd
give you my uh ranking of all MCU Titles
since endgame and here it is this is
just mine not tomies and this is subject
to change this is how I'm feeling right
now uh I last shared this when I uh
reviewed Marvel's so I believe Ekko is
like right uh right above Thor love and
thunder uh I like She-Hulk just a little
bit more and uh just to kind of go every
title beneath this easy win over secret
Invasion secret Invasion Remains the
worst thing I think Marvel Studios has
ever done um and again this is just a
list of things since endgame uh but I
believe black widow just had even more
issues of um like lack of clarity of
what that movie was supposed to be to
whom uh it was was supposed to be Black
Widow but it was more of yena bov anyway
I just had issues with black widow
eternals I get that there are eternals
Defenders I hear you I respect you I
think that movie was a huge misfire and
the actors had no chemistry with each
other and was just not fun to watch I
think the Falcon Winter Soldier started
off promising uh but with the character
of John Walker was just such a confusing
pivot for the character in the way that
series ended the the fact that they took
out the Mama da flag Smasher storyline I
no what was going on Thor 11 Thunder
obviously Tao atiti gave up on that
movie and I will always rank a title
where the showrunner or director still
believes in it over one where the
director clearly stopped believing in it
I mean I know people had issues with
She-Hulk I love the meta ending of
She-Hulk it ended in such a fun place I
think ekko's just the way it ended was
just such you know just kind of a bum
yeah so that's why I've ranked it the
way I I love any show that ends on a
campaign launch uh personally any show
that any show that answers the question
is he running onward onward Tommy this
was a difficult conversation to have I
uh you know Jessica is taking some time
off right now it's been her birthday
week she worked really hard on all this
Echo I would have loved to have her here
but we're gonna continue talking this
with Jessica because I could hear
Jessica from from wherever she is just
screaming at it's like you guys are
missing this so I understand it and
Jessica I'm sorry I well I'm so glad we
got to talk Eric I think you know I I
know you're hard on yourself about being
fair but I think that you are you're
you're you're genuinely trying to come
from a good place often in a place that
goes often often a notion that goes
unrewarded by toxic fandom so I applaud
you for well and Tommy I appreciate you
giving me uh that patience uh and that
um that understanding and I really loved
hearing from you and all your thoughts
about this and you've also just been
very fair as someone who who can express
their uh gratitude and their
appreciation of stuff while also
understanding that things are flly and
that not every project works as well as
it wanted absolutely love you Tommy it
was great to catch up with you happy New
Year happy year and to everyone give the
family a hug from me everyone in the
comments below be civil with each other
obviously this is a difficult uh thing
to talk about either way but I really
enjoyed watching this show overall I
enjoyed chatting about with you Tommy
follow Tommy at Tommy be told you follow
me at eaos uh grab some merch From Nerd
r. shop to support new rockstars is the
best way you can support us we
appreciate all you guys we love you guys
and we'll see you soon by by
[Music]
[Applause]
everybody